hi I'm Andrew Phillips head of the
biological computation group at
Microsoft Research in Cambridge and in
this demo I'll be presenting some of the
work we've been doing on computer
software for programming cells so cells
are the building blocks of life and if
we program cells as effectively as we
program digital computers we can make
fundamental breakthroughs in the
treatment of disease the development of
sustainable agriculture and the
production of clean energy in spite of
this potential there's still many
challenges to overcome
first and foremost programming cells is
highly complex and error-prone and
powerful computer software is needed to
accelerate for the progress so in this
demo I'll be presenting computer
software for programming cells at three
levels DNA molecules single cells and
cell colonies at the level of DNA
molecules we've developed a programming
language for designing molecular
circuits made of DNA such circuits can
be inserted into cells to monitor the
health of the cell and to trigger
appropriate responses such as killing
the cell if it becomes cancerous without
harming neighboring healthy cells in
collaboration with the lab of George
Selig at the University of Washington
and with Luca car deli in the
programming languages group we've
developed an approximate majority
algorithm in DNA which determines the
consensus between two populations and
computes the majority in optimal time so
we can get very accurate correspondence
between simulation of our computational
models shown in dashed lines an actual
experimental data shown in solid lines
using the Phils buck parameter
estimation tool we can also reliably
predict the behavior of the circuits in
terms of the behavior of its components
so here I'm showing you demo of the
software in action we have a program do
you know our consensus algorithm when we
compile that program we can actually
obtain the behavior in terms of the
interactions between DNA molecules and
we can simulate this behavior over time
in collaboration with the constraint
reasoning group we've also used z3
desert 3 theorem prover to be able to
detect errors in our circuit design let
me analyze a circuit if an error is
detected dead three reproduces a trace
that shows how the error was a
at the level of single cells we've
developed we've been developing computer
software for programming genetic devices
in terms of genes and proteins in
collaboration with the lab of Jim
Hasselhoff at the University of
Cambridge Rodger developed a method for
characterizing genetic parts in order to
predict the behavior of systems or
devices made of those parts more
accurately the method actually uses a
reference signal in order to compensate
for changes in environmental conditions
such as changes in temperature to give
more robust predictions so here we see
that our method can more accurately
predict circuit dynamics in terms of the
ability of a circuit to take in a signal
over time and a distance at the level of
cell colonies we've been developing
methods for simulating the interactions
physical interactions between
neighboring cells as they grow and
divide so again in collaboration with
the hassle of lab at the University of
Cambridge we've developed a method that
can actually simulate entire micro
colonies of cells in three dimensions
using GPU graphics processing unit
technology so here we see a simulation
of four cell colonies shown in four
different colors as they grow adjacent
to one another and we can actually
obtain good correspondence between
experiments on the left and simulations
on the right if we do a simulation where
we change the shape of the cell so they
are now round instead of rod-shaped we
obtain quite different boundaries
between the cell colonies you can see
here and it turns out that these
predictions can actually be borne out by
experiments so by integrating
computational models at the level of
molecules cells and cell colonies we can
actually obtain more accurate prediction
of the behavior of cell programs so we
anticipate that software for programming
cells could one day be at the heart of
new industries and biotechnology thanks
you